ja vielen dank frau busch aus dass wir
auch hier ihre gäste sein dürfen ich
möchte auch bedanken dass kollege
karagiannis heute mit dazu gekommen ist
und uns die situation auf den
intensivstationen aber nicht nur da sein
wird und auch vielen dank vieler dass
sie wieder dabei sind in bewährter
manier ich komme mal kurz zunächst auch
die situation zu sprechen wo sind wir
derzeit ich glaube wir haben jetzt hat
die omikron welle in deutschland gut in
der kontrolle das ist eine also welle
für die gilt dass man also die welle
selbst die pandemische welle nicht
kontrollieren kann man kann aber die
folgen kontrollieren das ist unser ziel
wir wollen die folgen minimieren dass
sie was wir ausgegeben haben auch als
bundesregierung auch in abstimmung also
mit bundeskanzler scholz aber nicht nur
ist dass wir durch diese welle durch
kommen wollen mit zum wenigen den
schweren verläufen und todesfällen wie
möglich das ist das ziel was wir uns
gesetzt haben und dafür muss es erreicht
werden dass möglichst viele ältere
menschen durch diese welle durch kommen
ohne dass sie schwer erkrankt und wir
haben in deutschland ein sonderproblem
wir haben eine sehr alte bevölkerung die
zweitälteste bevölkerung in europa nach
italien und wir haben darüber hinaus
eine sehr hohe zahl von ungeimpften in
dieser hohen altersgruppe bei den über
60 jährigen wir haben dort firma so
viele ungeimpfte wie england und dreimal
so viele ungeimpfte wie italien das
heißt wir haben das besondere sind die
besondere situation sehr viele ältere
menschen und von dieser besonders
bedrohten gruppe sind viele im vergleich
zu anderen ländern umkämpft daher müssen
wir diese also gruppe schützen das ist
das ziel unserer maßnahmen und das ist
keine kleinigkeit obwohl nikon leichter
verläuft müssen wir damit rechnen dass
viele von diesen ältere menschen wenn
sie ungeimpft erkranken so schwer
erkranken dass sie intensiv wichtig
werden unter verstärken das ist das
problem also es wird dann fehlen so
gehen und daher muss man hier seine
zwischenbilanz abgeben die
zwischenbilanz ist bisher positiv wir
haben hohe instanzen das hat nicht
überrascht ich habe hier in dieser runde
schon vorgetragen wir rechnen mit
täglichen instanzen von bis zu 400.000
fällen wir glauben aber also dass die
incidents dann wieder runter geht wir
wollen eben erreichen dass in dieser
welle möglichst wenige ältere menschen
erkranken und dass es bisher gelungen
die incidents ist im durchschnitt 1000
bei den jüngeren ist die inzidenz zum
teil
2000 aber war dieser variablen gruppe
auf die es uns so besonders ankommt
liegt sie zwischen 200 und 300 und das
ist sozusagen unser erfolg weil ich lese
oft und höre oft die politik hätte die
kontrolle in dieser welle verloren das
ist nicht der fall mit den hohen
fallzahlen hatten wir gerechnet ich habe
sie hier vorgetragen sie sind sogar
etwas niedriger als das modell des
robert-koch-instituts vorher berechnet
hatte wir liegen unter diesen
vorhersagen aber es ist uns gelungen die
älteren bisher durch die maßnahmen die
wir haben 3g 2g 3g plus die älteren gut
zu schützen das werden wir weiter machen
und dafür werden wir jetzt auch noch ein
paar anpassungen vornehmen wir fahren
weiter die booster kampagne die poster
kampagne ist etwas zurückgegangen auch
das ist keine überraschung denn also
auch bei der booster kampagne ist es so
diejenigen die besonders überzeugt sind
melden sich zuerst diejenigen die man
schwerer überzeugen kann die werden sich
danach darüber hinaus omikron gilt als
etwas harmloser sind jetzt viele der
mann fälschlicherweise dass die booster
impfung nicht notwendig wäre das spielt
uns nicht gerade in die karten
und dazu kommt viele haben mit sorge die
booster impfung die mit dem alten
impfstoff erfolgt ist vielleicht nicht
optimal man möge warten bis die omikron
soeben vom auch das ist falsch durch die
drei punkte ganz kurz durch die booster
impfung hilft den eltern unbedingt dort
ich rufe dort jeden auf die
boost-funktion nehmen zum zweiten die
alte neben stoffe die wir jetzt noch
haben moderne aber auch bei und wir
haben es jetzt in der in dem umfang zur
verfügung wir es brauchen schützen
drastisch foto das die centers of
disease control haben jetzt noch einmal
ausgewertet dass das risiko zu sterben
durch die booster impfung im vergleich
zum ungeimpften status um 99 prozent
sind und zwar mit diesen alten stoffen
mit den impfstoffen die wir vor zwei
jahren entwickelt haben sinkt das risiko
zu sterben um 99% ich appelliere daher
von dieser stelle nochmal von diesem
sitz klassenraum weg bitte lassen sie
sich postern sie tun sich den größten
gefallen den sie sich tun können warten
sie nicht auf impfstoffe die noch in der
entwicklung sind nehmen sie dem stoff
für die da sind 99 prozent wird das also
risiko gesenkt wir werden in der
nächsten woche in kona schutzmaßnahmen
ausnahmeverordnung noch einmal anpassen
in bezug auf die isolations freiheit es
um bei den also medizinischen kritisch
menschen bei diesem personal wir werden
eine neue tasten test strategie und test
verordnung vorliegen eng abgestimmt mit
den ländern und wir werden darüber
hinaus auch regeln für die
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung vorlegen
auch sehr eng abgestimmt mit den ländern
hier arbeiten an allen drei
regeln schon sehr intensiv mit den
ländern zusammen die letzten
besprechungen mit einer untergruppe der
länder hat es gestern nacht so
stattgefunden 21 uhr stattgefunden darin
wird sehr intensiv gearbeitet ich komme
also zum ende meiner auswirkung wir also
kontrollieren die welle unser ziel ist
es durch diese welle größe kommen dass
wir dann zurückblicken können und sagen
in deutschland sind sehr wenige ältere
menschen in dieser schweren omikron
welle noch gestorben weil wir sie gut
schützen konnte das möchte ich dass man
darauf zurückblickt und dann schaut das
war ein erfolg werden sowohl fahrer
zahlen gehabt aber weniger sterbefälle
und dass wir in den nächsten
monaten es schaffen so schnell wie
möglich schneller desto besser einen
rückfall abzuwenden im herbst durch die
einführung der allgemeinen impfung nicht
so dass man am ende des jahres dann
schauen kann und sagt die omikron welle
das hat deutschland gut geschafft da
sind wir mit wenigen positionen
durchgekommen hatten wir in der
kontrolle und einen schweren rückfall
hat es im herbst nicht gegeben weil
diese im pflücke die ich eben
beschrieben aber diese zwölf prozent bei
den über 60-jährigen die schließt sich
nicht von allein ich schließe sich nicht
durch appelle die schließt sich nicht
indem wir also auf die risiken hinweisen
sondern die diskussion ist so verfahren
dass wir diese lücke ausmaß sich nur
schließen werden mit der einführung
einer allgemeinen pflicht und die muss
auch früh kommen weil wenn sie nicht
früh kommt wird sie im herbst die impf
abdeckung nicht erreicht haben die wir
benötigen um diesen erfolg zu
ermöglichen so sehe ich die derzeitige
situation
und ja ich würde es dabei schon belassen
wollen gibt das wort so seien sie von
pusch
daniela haben sie das wort ja tag meine
damen und herren die fallzahlen steigen
weiter massiv an aber tatsächlich
steigen sie bei weitem nicht so heftig
wie es unter omikron möglich wäre und
das liegt daran dass sich die
allermeisten menschen verantwortungsvoll
daran halten an die maßnahmen die sie
alle kennen und ihre kontakte reduzieren
damit können wir folgen extrem hohe
fallzahlen für krankenhäuser und auch
für die versorgung allgemein noch etwas
geringer gehalten werden und wir
gewinnen tatsächlich mit jedem tag zeit
an dem sich viele weitere menschen
impfen lassen können und auch eine
auffrischungsimpfung nehmen und dadurch
wird die anzahl der schweren
krankheitsverläufe reduziert das ist
genau das wichtige und richtige ziel
trotzdem muss man natürlich klar sagen
dass wir in der mikrowelle jetzt
sozusagen auf einen höhepunkt zu steuern
wie sieht also die aktuelle lage aus
allein in den letzten sieben tagen haben
sich in deutschland rund 890.000
menschen infiziert das ist also quasi
ein prozent der gesamten bevölkerung das
in nur einer woche jeder dritte
durchgeführte pcr test in der letzten
woche war positiv aber ich hatte ja
schon gesagt dass wir mit micon in eine
neue phase der pandemie eintreten und
das in dieser jetzigen phase der
pandemie die summe der fallzahlen nicht
mehr das entscheidende ist wir müssen
jetzt in erster linie auf die
krankheitslast
und die krankheit schwerer schauen denn
das ziel bleibt weiterhin schwere
verläufe zu verringern und die
arbeitsfähigkeit von kliniken aber
natürlich auch von anderen kritischen
infrastrukturen aufrecht zu halten
und schauen wir mal auf die relevanten
parameter die sieben tage
hospitalisierung incidents liegt
adjustiert schon bei rund
75 und sie steigt aktuell dh die zahl
der stationär behandlungs dürftigen
cupid 19 patienten ist hoch und die
krankenhäuser bekommen das jetzt
[Musik]
tja lothar wieder spricht hier von der
hospitalisierung rate die jetzt schon
bei 7 liegt ein relativ hoher wert aber
das rk ii unterscheidet bis heute nicht
zwischen patienten die wegen corona ins
krankenhaus kommen und patienten die mit
corona kommen und wir haben vor kurzem
viele bundesländer abgefragt das hat
meine kollegin lydia rosenfeld getan und
heraus kam in vielen bundesländern sind
mehr patienten mit corona also mit neben
ursache corona im grand pas aber nicht
wegen corona das verfälscht diesen wert
und dieser wert sollte ganz schnell
wieder angepasst werden an die realität
um nicht panik zu verbreiten
und das ist ja klar dass hier die quote
der geimpften und auffrischimpfung bei
den jüngeren fiel bei den älteren viel
höher ist als bei den jugendlichen und
jungen erwachsenen aber sie ist eben
noch nicht ausreichend hoch genug
auf zwei dinge sollten wir in den
nächsten beiden wochen besonders achten
erstens selbst wenn der anteil der
infektionen durch micon mit schweren
verläufen geringer ist als bei delta
müssen wir allein durch die schiere
menge an infizierten wieder mit mehr
krankenhauseinweisungen rechnen das
sehen wir jetzt schon zweitens werden in
den kommenden wochen immer mehr eltern
wollen menschen betroffen seien und wie
infektion mit omikron bei ihnen
verlaufen das können wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht genau einschätzen
wir befinden uns in einer neuen phase
der pandemie von beginn an haben wir die
strategie der eindämmung des schutzes
und der abmilderung verfolgt und in der
jetzigen pandemie phase kann aufgrund
der extrem hohen fallzahlen eine
eindämmung nur noch auf die wichtigsten
bereiche konzentriert werden unsere
strategie hat sich nicht geändert aber
weil inzwischen viele personen geimpft
sind oder den natürlichen kontakt mit
dem virus durch eine infektion hatten
müssen wir mit blick auf die sehr hohen
fallzahlen nun noch stärker den fokus
auf den schutz insbesondere der
wohlhabenden gruppen
denn das ist entscheidend jetzt müssen
die risikogruppen wieder ganz intensiv
geschützt werden was sich aber immer
mehr abzeichnet und das ist die
entscheidende botschaft wer geimpft ist
am besten dreifach geimpft ist ist in
der regel sehr gut vor schweren
verläufen auch mit hongkong geschützt
nach wie vor gilt je mehr infektionen
wir verhindern je langsamer als ich saß
kopf zwei ausbreitet desto besser
schützen wir die wohlhabenden
mitmenschen und auch die kritischen
infrastruktur das gilt auch jetzt noch
auch bei nikon auch bei den massiven
fallzahlen wir dürfen uns von der
mikrowelle nicht überwältigen lassen
oder um bei dem tanker bild zu bleiben
dass ich an dieser stelle schon mal
bemüht habe die see ist stürmisch ja
und die sicht ist schlecht aber wir
müssen jetzt wirklich einen kühlen kopf
bewahren den tanker weiter auf kurs
halten und gemeinsam durch diesen strom
fahren wir wissen genau wo wir hinwollen
wir trotzen auch dieser welle auch sie
wird vorbeigehen und bis dahin halten
wir bitte weiter unsere kontakte gering
vermeiden wir
menschenansammlungen
tragen wir maske und zwar eng anliegen
über mund und nase
und lüften wir und regelmäßig wenn wir
mit ihren menschen
man hört hier einen ganz neuen ton von
lothar wieler bislang haben wir immer
den alarm lkw schiff gehört der etwas
mehr panik verbreitet hat und auch immer
relativ pessimistisch klangen jetzt sagt
man wir kommen hier durch wir lassen uns
nicht von der welle überwältigen ich
glaube da merken einige unter anderem
los sei wieder und auch karl lauterbach
das ist eine andere welt und diese
panikmache die wird von den menschen
auch gar nicht mehr verstanden die kommt
nicht an denn wir sehen die infektion
schießen zwar wirklich in den himmel
aber die krankenhäuser fühlen sich nicht
und das ist nicht nur in deutschland so
das ist in allen anderen ländern so die
um uns herum diese omikron welle schon
längst haben das war übrigens auch in
großbritannien sowie die fälle noch
deutlich höher waren aber die
krankenhäuser haben das alles sehr gut
verkraftet das heißt diese vorherigen
alarmrufe dass wir kurz vor dem kollaps
stehen dass man jetzt maßnahmen
verschärfen muss die übrigens auch
lothar wieler vor kurzem noch
verschärfen wollte wegen der mikrowelle
das muss man jetzt nicht tun wir erleben
hier ein lothar wieler der glaube ich
auch etwas sein image retten möchte
dass wir so gesehen haben in der
lungenheilkunde und auf die
intensivstation in den letzten 20 jahren
mit unglaublich vielen schweren und zehn
verläufen was wir aber auch sehen ist
dass wir so seit ungefähr sieben bis
zehn tagen eine seitwärtsbewegung bei
den neuaufnahmen haben hin zu einem
trend dass es jetzt vielleicht hoch geht
und das ist ziemlich eindeutig der
omicron effekte jetzt auch den
intensivstationen ankommt das ist alles
akzeptabel
aber es liegt natürlich daran dass wir
jetzt auch vermehrt diese hohen inzidenz
neben krankenhaus sehen
auf den normalen stationen stets die
situation etwas anders da als auf den
intensivstationen und wenn wir das
beispiel nordrhein-westfalen nehmen da
haben wir eine sehr gute realtime
übersicht über die kogit patienten jeden
tag und wir haben den stärksten anstieg
der cold patienten im krankenhaus seit
beginn der pandemie und sind heute schon
wieder auf der spitze der del tabelle
mit knapp dreieinhalb tausend patienten
und das geht sehr deutlich und das wird
noch deutlicher werden mit den hohen in
citizen und das führt uns natürlich auf
jeden fall ganz klar auch zu der frage
was sehen wir dort für patienten ich
will immer wieder die frage gestellt
kommen die mit oder wegen corona ich
darf sie vielleicht bitten die frage
umzuformulieren weil wenn sie einen
patienten vor sich haben gerade auf der
intensivstation er kann den luftkrieg
und sie fragen den sind sie jetzt hier
mit oder wegen corona dann springt er
ihnen geradeaus ins gesicht
ich glaube dass bessere learning ist
dass wir davon sprechen welche
krankheitslast haben wir mit der omicron
variante was ist die hauptdiagnose die
den patienten ins krankenhaus führt das
ist ganz wichtig und wie viele von denen
haben auch wirklich ein respiratorische
problem also wie viele von denen haben
die pneumologie und ich glaube schon
dass wir auch im jetzigen system
möglichkeiten haben das zu überwachen
und lothar wieder hat sie eben
angesprochen wir haben die syndrom ische
überwachung des aks das heißt wir wissen
wie viele atemwegserkrankungen wir haben
intensiv register aber auch die
möglichkeit zumindest surrogat parameter
dafür zu finden was auf den
intensivstationen passiert und sie
wissen alle dass der anteil der
beatmeten patienten extrem hoch ist bei
coop it und der liegt zum teil bei bis
zu 90 prozent mit der respiratorischen
unterstützung das war so die spitze der
del tabelle und wir haben einen kleinen
anteil der wird bei uns als danone
respiratorische unterstützung geführt
der nacht auf der spitze der delta werde
bei 10 prozent und wenn sie jetzt
zunehmend patienten haben die aufgrund
anderer gründe im krankenhaus landen
oder auf der intensivstation dann steigt
dieser anteil natürlich und was wir
stand heute sehen ist dass der anteil
jetzt bei ungefähr 20 prozent liegt und
das reflektiert auch ein bisschen dass
sie mehr andere patienten haben die das
virus mitbringen aber wir sollten nicht
vergessen dass co wird keine reine
lungenerkrankungen ist oder in dem
system erkrankungen die insbesondere
auch die gefäß zu betreten das wird mir
immer ein bisschen zu sehr vergessen
weil gerade diese entzündungsreaktion in
den innenstädten der gefäße jedes organ
mit einbeziehen kann und ich glaube wir
müssen jetzt sehr genau den nächsten
wochen gucken wie sich dieser anteil
dieser fälle entwickelt die keine arten
unterstützung braucht und wie gesagt von
10 auf 20 prozent ist ein moment und ich
erwarte dass wir in den nächsten wochen
vielleicht noch stärker werden das heißt
wir haben auch stand jetzt schon eine
überwachung dessen was wir für einen
patientenkollektiv auf den
intensivstationen haben nichtsdestotrotz
und ich glaube das ist mir besonders
wichtig für den kommenden winter auf den
müssen wir uns wirklich gut vorbereiten
ich habe mehr angst vor dem kommenden
winter als vor diesem und das führt uns
auch da hin dass wir uns jetzt glaube
ich so vorbereiten müssen dass wir
patienten individuelle daten ausleiten
und ich bin guter dinge dass wir das mit
karl lauterbach und lothar wieder
schaffen werden im laufe dieses jahres
systeme zu etablieren dass wir im
nächsten winter gut sagen können welcher
patient dicht auf den intensiv und
normal stationen
ein punkt der mir noch wichtig ist die
kritische infrastruktur und wir haben in
unserer ersten stellungnahme des
expertenrates schon darauf hingewiesen
dass die kritische infrastruktur unter
stress geraten wird und wenn wir heute
200.000 infektionen haben und nächste
woche vielleicht 400.000 dann ist das
ein echter stresstest für die kritische
infrastrukturen im land ich bin sehr
dankbar dass viele unsere anregung
aufgegriffen haben und dienstpläne noch
mal überarbeitet haben und sich gut
darauf vorbereitet haben aber ich glaube
die nächsten wochen werden nicht nur in
den krankenhäusern hart werden weil viel
personal ausfällt und auch viele kinder
einfach zu hause betreut werden müssen
von eltern die in der kritischen
infrastruktur arbeiten selbst wenn sie
selbst nicht infiziert sind und zum
abschluss sein wir noch mal ein
persönliches wort gestattet an die
mitarbeiter
[Musik]
professor doktor karagiannis vom
intensivmediziner verband die wie von
ihm hätte ich mir wirklich etwas mehr
klarheit erhofft denn er hat erklärt
wenn da ein patient kommt ein schwer
kranker mensch dann könne man ihn ja
nicht fragen ob er mit oder wegen corona
da ist der würde einem sonst ins gesicht
springen ehrlich gesagt ist das ja auch
nicht die aufgabe der ärzte die
patienten zu fragen ob sie mit oder
wegen corona da sind gleich wissen dass
die patientin auch gar nicht das merken
die ärzte glaube ich aber auch selbst
zumindest sagen mir dass ärzte im
gespräch vom die wie vom
intensivmediziner verband dem auch
professor korrigiertes angehört erwarte
ich dass sie diese daten liefern und
zwar dass sie sauber liefern und nicht
versuchen kritischen journalisten die
fragen stellen vorzuschreiben wie sie
ihre fragen zu stellen haben es ist ein
wunder mit also es eine so zentrale
information zu wissen wie viele menschen
wegen kowitz ins krankenhaus müssen und
wie viele nur mit cupid ins krankenhaus
müssen andere länder in europa müssen
das sehr sauber auf deutschland leider
nicht
die möglichkeit kriegen eine frage zu
stellen das gilt natürlich auch für die
online eingereichten fragen
ich werde dann im zweifel einfach nur
die erste nehmen und ich beginne mit
fragen die online gestellt wurden co2
zusammen weil es bei beiden um das thema
was ändert sich bei den tests geht julia
frisch von der ärzte zeitung fragt wann
ist mit der neuen test verordnung
bezüglich der priorisierung der pcr test
zu rechnen und werden wegen der
priorisierung andere personengruppen gar
keinen anspruch mehr auf einen pcr-test
haben und christina hofmann ähnliche
frage was wird sich beim testen und der
kontakt nach folgen konkret ändern
ja ich denke die fragen gehen an mich
vielen dank wir werden in der nächsten
woche eine entsprechende
testwerte vorliegen wir sind in der
abstimmung mit den der schon erwähnt
dass gestern abend 21 uhr noch einmal
eine runde mit einigen ländern gedreht
wurde werden am wochenende weiter
arbeiten das ist als bedürftig und in
der nächsten woche werden wir also einen
vorschlag mit den ländern gemeinsam
unterbreiten und
priorisierung sagt ist ja schon das
bedeutet nicht dass diejenigen die nicht
die priorität haben gar keinen anspruch
haben aber ihr anspruch ist sekundär und
es ist ja klar die details sind noch
vorzubehalten aber es ist ganz klar dass
hier zwei gruppen in der priorisierung
besondere bedeutung haben das ist zum
einen die gruppe derer die also in den
bereichen pflege
altenpflege krankenpflege aber auch in
der eingliederungshilfe tätig sind weil
dort muss der pcr test dazu führen dass
man eine mögliche infektion so schnell
feststellt dass man die schutzbefohlenen
dass man die noch schützen kann das muss
gesichert sein dass wir da nicht wie vor
einem jahr also in todesfälle haben die
wir nicht wollen dass nur ein
schwerpunkt sein wir wollen das einfach
gar nicht wir wollen dass in diesen
bereichen tatsächlich die pcr test um
absolute priorität hat und dann gibt es
natürlich auch eine andere gruppe
besonders wollen habe liszt zum beispiel
menschen mit schweren erkrankungen die
also eine erkrankung also mit omikron
nur überstehen könnten wenn man sie also
früh behandelt und zu dieser frühen
behandlung gehört auch die medikamentöse
verbannung die antikörper behandlungen
also die bewegung mit paco wird was wir
rechtzeitig beschaffen konnten wo wir
jetzt also mit der lieferung rechnen
aber wir haben auch noch andere
medikamente und so rettet man leben wenn
jemand da sehr früh durch den pcr test
diagnostiziert wird und die behandlung
beginnt noch zu dem zeitpunkt nur eine
entweder antivirale komponente wirkt
oder das immunsystem unterstützen und
schützen sie also den menschen
dahingehend dass er dann überlebt was er
sonst nicht was sonst nicht passiert
wäre und das sind für uns auf jeden fall
ich wähle der also verordnung nicht
vorgreifen wir arbeiten intensiv daran
dass es sind auf jeden fall zwei gruppen
die dort auch die dort auf jeden fall
genannt zu haben und wie gesagt wenn
dann noch test pcr-test lassen sie mich
ein punkt noch sagen es wird sicherlich
auch noch gefragt werden das greife ich
stand vorab aus wieso machen wir das
nicht in wien gepolt es weiter also das
sind zwei dinge zu sagen zum einen also
geburt es hätten dazu geführt dass wir
jetzt eine höhere kapazität hätten aber
so etwas muss man vorberaten und zwar
bevorzugt zu dem zeitpunkt wo es nicht
viele fälle gibt denn wenn sie die
labors umstellen wollen auch wenn
solches verfahren machen sie das am
besten wenn nicht gerade so eine große
belastung ist jetzt wäre das vollkommen
unmöglich und das dauert seine zeit ich
hatte das selbst im mai 2020 für den
sommer dann den sommer 20 vorgeschlagen
ich hatte es auch noch mal vorgeschlagen
für den sommer 21 dass es damals nicht
gemacht worden wir haben uns für eine
andere strategie in deutschland
entschieden die an die internet
strategie das ist aber auch eine gute
testate gibt man darf jetzt nicht alles
schlecht reden der anti gen test ist für
die also nicht priorisierten bereiche
ist das sehr hilfreich weil da wird zwar
am anfang der infektion anzahl der fälle
übersehen
aber das sind dann die fälle die also
auch noch nicht so stark also infektiös
sind das andere angesteckt werden
könnten somit wenn man die anti gen test
klug ansetzt dann kann man auch mit
dieser strategie die mikrowelle sehr gut
beherrschen und das war ja die strategie
für die wir uns hier entschieden hatten
die für die sich auch meine vorgänger
entschieden hatten das ist jetzt auch
nicht zu kritisieren aber wir dürfen
nicht den fehler machen dass wir sagen
jetzt haben wir nur die anti gen test
wir haben keine kontrolle sondern wenn
man den die antigen testflug einsetzt
dann kann man die welle damit gut
beherrschen insbesondere beim freiheit
testen wo der antigen test sehr sicher
ist und daran beginnt es ist auch sehr
also spezifisch wenn er jetzt positiv
ist war bei der hohen prävalenz das wird
kollege wieder bestätigen wollen je
höher die prävalenz desto größer ist der
wert eines positiven also antigen test
der sogenannte positive voraussage wert
ist dann höher und damit ist also in der
jetzigen situation der antigen test
schon gut unterwegs und also jetzt
darüber zu lamentieren
was wäre gewesen wenn wir an pulling
angeführt hatte das führt uns in der
krise nicht weiter
der charakter ist sie wollten dazu
ergänzt ja ich würde gerne noch einen
punkt ergänzen in der
gesundheitsminister gerade aufgebaut hat
müssen die neuen therapieformen und
wir haben seit dieser woche in
deutschland ja nicht nur die aktive
immunisierung mit mit den impfstoffen
sondern wir haben
gehört und vor allem haben wir sehr viel
ich sag mal fachchinesisch
gehört und priwall enzen und so garten
und so weiter und so fort das ist eine
bundespressekonferenz eine
pressekonferenz die ja auch zur
aufklärung der bevölkerung dienen soll
philipp ehrlich gesagt sind dann da doch
einige rätsel mit dabei ja ich also
eigentlich hätten lothar wieler und karl
lauterbach über das thema der woche den
vergangenen beiden wochen sprechen
müssen und das ist das thema verkürzung
des genesenen status ist es immer noch
nicht klar wer was wusste es ist noch
nicht klar warum das
robert-koch-institut auf eigene faust
gehandelt hat warum karl lauterbach
nicht informiert wurde warum dann die
ganze bevölkerung über nacht überrumpelt
wurde mit der verkürzung des genesenen
status und mit der aberkennung des
impfstatus von johnson & johnson
kämpften das sind die großen fragen
eigentlich hätte es sich gehört dass
zumindest lothar wieler der bislang
geschwiegen hat dazu sich dazu erst mal
erklärt bringt die ehrlich gesagt die
allgemeine lage das ist ja bekannt was
über das was gerade passiert die
menschen sehen das ja die zahlen steigen
die infektionszahlen und sehr hoch die
krankenhaus belastung ist nicht so hoch
ich habe nicht verstanden warum karl
lauterbach erstmal die maßnahmen gelobt
hat ich habe auch genug andere länder in
den vergangenen wochen gesehen in denen
man auch ohne maßnahmen sehr gut durch
diese wellen kam man sieht es jetzt in
dänemark die lockern auf dem höhepunkt
der mikrowelle und dass er erklärt hat
dass sich gerade junge menschen
anstecken oder vermehrt und die älteren
noch nie zu sehr das läge an den
maßnahmen das habe ich überhaupt nicht
verstanden 2g und 3g das gilt auch für
alle zweig ships die älteren doch nicht
besser als die jüngeren vielleicht hängt
es auch damit zusammen wer wie oft
getestet wird jüngere menschen gehen
natürlich sehr viel öfter weg lassen
sich vielleicht deshalb auch sehr viel
öfter testen wir wissen dass er bei
kindern die in die schule gehen und
jeden tag fast getestet werden deswegen
sorgt dass dort natürlich für besonders
hohe instanzen also mir war das ein
bisschen viel zu viel spekulation
verbunden mit selbstlob wo doch beide
wissen wie la und lauterbach dass sie
gerade in einer ziemlich großen
vertrauenskrise sind die sie selbst ja
angerichtet haben da das ist ja nicht
die schuld von irgendjemandem nicht die
schuld von corona sondern sie haben eine
entscheidung getroffen damit die länder
überrumpelt damit die bevölkerung
überrumpelt und sie weigern sich immer
noch wirklich aufzuklären ein argument
was karl lauterbach gleich zu beginn
dieser pressekonferenz gebracht hat was
bei mir sehr hängen geblieben ist war
der der punkt sollten wir haben hier in
deutschland ein sonderproblem weil wir
eine sehr alte bevölkerung haben und
ernannte dann das wäre auf platz zwei
sind nur italien hätte noch eine ältere
bevölkerung ist das wirklich kann das
ein grund sein dass wir hier immer noch
keine lockerung haben von maßnahmen kann
das vielleicht auch ein grund sein dafür
dass der genesenen status bei uns jetzt
nur noch drei monate gilt also ich würde
sagen karl lauterbach findet immer ein
grund oder eine begründung um zu
begründen dass die massnahmen bleiben
sollen das alter ist natürlich ein
wesentlicher faktor
das stimmt aber es gibt auch andere
faktoren beispielsweise ist das so dass
menschen in anderen ländern
die deutlich ärmer sind ein deutlich
schlechteres gesundheitssystem haben
dort sind die menschen auch wenn sie im
durchschnitt nicht zu alt sind weniger
gesund als in deutschland die ernährung
ist schlechter die lebensverhältnisse
ist ein schlechter die arbeit ist härter
auch das wirkt sich ja aus und in
deutschland wir sind nun mal ein sehr
wohlhabendes land auch wenn wir eine
relativ alte bevölkerung haben und wenn
wir schauen wie corona also wie
gefährlich coroner für soziale schichten
ist das ist ja auch alles längst
erwiesen dann sieht man beim sozial
schwächere schichten sind deutlich
stärker von corinna betroffen deswegen
ist es auch so dass ärmere länder oft
stärker unter kroner leiden und
deutschland ist eine wirtschafts nation
nummer eins deswegen nur alles mit dem
all zu begründen und mit einigen
millionen ungeimpften älteren ich glaube
das reicht nicht viele piraten für die
einordnung